would you recommend to not that strong
player for analyzing their own games
especially when the engine
recommendations goes over my head yeah
yep you do have to be careful using the
engine I mean the engine will still give
you kind of some feedback it doesn't
always do a great job of explaining why
something should be played or why
something should not be played but yeah
it does help to like to analyze your
games with someone whether it be a
training partner or coach I think the
first step to analyzing your games is to
have have have a system for organizing
things so if you're a tournament player
or if you're at like online player
whatever serious games you play you
should you should save probably easiest
for most people to just save them to
Ally chess study I go to learn study
rookie mistakes
thanks for the bits make a new study if
you want it to be completely private
selecting by only and then depending on
whether you're playing online like you
can import games using the game URL if
you're playing a tournament you can
enter your games just on a new board you
can add multiple chapters and I think
the first step is to like to annotate
your games so rather than trying to do
like deep analysis just go through the
game and like comment on what was going
through your mind while you played the
game so if I bring in the last game I
played I'll copy the link address oops
what did I do with the study here's a
study it's out of chapter
paste the link address and the board so
and if you're like analyzing the opening
you can very easily use a the opening
reference and sometimes this is this is
uh just a good start
to see what strong players do in the
openings that you play so if we wanted
to see a game let's say from whites
perspective where white wins let's look
at Kasparov we can insert this game
within the study so now there's a new
variation containing Kasparov Shira and
oh this is this is a rook takes p7 game
this is actually a really famous game I
remember seeing this game of chess camp
so they played the main line of the
special economy
oh this is such a beautiful game rook
takes p7 it might help to like fine
annotations like try and find this game
in the book or annotations online but
this was a positional sacrifice to play
d4 and the light was just a dead piece
and then Kasparov went on to win so yeah
generally when I analyze my own games I
I try and find at least like a a high
level like grandmaster game or two to
come have used to build up my my
knowledge my arsenal of tools but if
you're going through like a middle game
you can sometimes make comments like I
do this for students on occasion where
like you can use a little buns here I
would say Knight takes c6 is dubious
this strengthens
Black's Center on center comfortable
position so Mike tp5 is a mainline some
eyes are studies you can find on me
chess with with annotations like this
and I think without with every game you
should have some goals like identify
some improvement on the opening identify
like the biggest plunger and sometimes
this can be used you can use the engine
to define like the biggest blunders
don't worry so much about inaccuracies
like here I think the h3 just missing
blacks
[Music]
and once you find the biggest plunger
you should find kind of the improvement
I would say most blenders in chess are
by missing the opponent's threat or not
not like acknowledging the puns play so
better it would be like Queenie -
probably another way to do this maybe
for for lazier people I'll bring in the
same game and you can go below and do
computer analysis now I know a little
the sum of analysis can go over your
head but if you want real quick feedback
you can do this like in the game
analysis board - but if you haven't
study then you can always save and look
back at it and over time it's nice to
build up like a collection of of your
games and then they try and see
tendencies throughout your games another
thing I would recommend okay so we
talked about opening improvements
identified blunders
at the very end I'd recommend like
comments just like a few lessons to take
away like lesson always identify points
[Music]
you should sense danger when your queen
is aligned with opponents or bishop for
that matter etc so yeah if we go back to
computer analysis right here you can see
kind of the summary and the computer
graph there's a lot of features here
it's like to dig into so like the one
blunder was yeah it was h3 I couldn't
look at mistakes - this sure takes you
seven was a mistake best move was b3
yeah this was probably a positional
mistake this is something that the
computer like would not under would not
explain it would be more difficult to
understand but with yeah with Bishop d7
the problem with this move is it gives
away LightSquared bishop so long-term
black will just be more effective in
controlling the lights queries and that
led to the tactics later with bishop
here and and d4 and white didn't have
his own LightSquared bishop to contest
blacks like squared bishop yeah so if if
you look at games between between
so-called noobs then there will be lots
more like kind of fluctuations it can be
fun
like generally a game a graph like this
is tells some some story much different
story than like a rollercoaster you
okay so hopefully that was useful for
for some people definitely upload to
YouTube I was more catering this to the
twitch chat but I guess I could upload
this to YouTube if people found that
valuable
yeah if YouTube people watching in the
future let me know what else you'd like
to to learn about these features maybe
I'll call this video like how to analyze
your own games and we chess it was a
quick synopsis but but yeah it's
something I can dig into a lot deeper